[Music]
oopsy yeah slow that down and freeze
that is demi lovato
accidentally crashing her rumoured
boyfriend's Instagram live on Saturday
sorry not sorry singer totally made an
unintentional cameo on max Elric's live
as he serenaded his fans on social media
I mean I don't know it's better Demi
walking into the shot with a blanket
blissfully unaware that the camera is
rolling or the look on Max's face as
he's trying to warn her that he's online
no wait that's the best part the look on
Danny's face and the moment the young
and restless star looks straight to
camera covers his mouth and laughs et
learned last week that the two are
dating a source revealed that the pair's
relationship was new and that they met
just a few weeks ago but they are really
enjoying spending time together fans
first noticed they were getting flirty
on social media and Danny left a
teary-eyed emoji and a red heart on a
video he posted on March 11 and while
Demi might have crashed his performance
he didn't crash hers the 27 year old
singer appeared on Sunday nights I heart
living room concert for America on Fox
where she played the piano and belted
her 2011 hit skyscraper the concert was
held to raise money for feeding America
and first responder Children's
Foundation both orgs are helping with
the corona virus outbreak when tragedy
knocks our neighbors down we extend our
hands to help them up when sorrow
strikes any one of us we do our best to
power through we can only use the love
we have to ease the pain we are strong
we are decent we will rise and stand
tall and nothing absolutely nothing can
tear us down
[Music]